the whole thing started for you i guess
when you found out your wife was
cheating on you
yeah so you know there was
or early in our relationship in our
marriage um i was traveling a lot uh
i was a consultant i was on the road um
and you know the work took me away from
the house and she
she kind of settled into this routine
with me not around
um initially for the first few few more
years of marriage now we were married
for almost 10 years
um and one of the things that we always
talked about together was
you know come off the road bob's going
to come off the road
and bob's going to be there with the
family and that's that was her goal
that was my goal you know and we were
both on the same page well
um i don't know if she thought it was
never going to happen but
i had an opportunity that brought me off
the road and kept me
you know home you know with her and the
kids 100 percent
and it was during that time where you
know i i saw
you know behavioral things that the
telltale signs if you will
what i call a distracted relationship um
you know social media on facebook all
the time
always on a cell phone um you know and
then
a couple red flags that started coming
up was you know she felt like this
she had this need for ladies night you
know she she needed a time away from the
kids to escape now
i didn't need such girls night out yeah
girls night out she
that was something that she had mandated
weekly and uh
and there was no boys night out for me
personally i mean
i had just come off the road you know
all my gratification was being at home
with my kids i didn't need to
hang out with the boys and have their
own careers you know she ever said
anything like hey you know do you want
to take a boy's night out
you know like once a week too or yeah
she did occasionally um
but you know once it was it was such a
funny flip-flop because one
once she did allow me to do that then
all of a sudden the text messages the
phone calls just being blown up
i didn't get any piece of mind to be out
with my quote-unquote boys
you know it was just her pestering me
the whole time and of course the rules
had always flipped on her side of the
table because i couldn't pester her you
know when she was out with the girls you
know
right you know lord forbid i ask her
where she's at and where she's going
what she's doing
so um so there was red flags initially
and then i started taking some
some steps uh they had a you know a
tracking
uh you could download we're on on the
same family plan on the cell phone so
you could download this
this family app that allows you to keep
tabs on your you know your significant
others
yeah and i you know i went ahead and i
downloaded that stuff you know just from
a safety precautionary standpoint took
that approach to it
uh she you know she really didn't buy
into it because she had things to hide
so she was really against the tracking
app for
you know whatever reasons and that was
another red flag to me personally was
okay well
she does you know she doesn't want to
tell me what she's doing on girls night
out and then at the same time
you know i don't have visibility she
won't allow the tracking app so
it was just the red flags just kept
mounting
and um and then i finally decided well
you know it's time maybe i take a peek
at her phone
so i i found an opportunity when she
wasn't around
um and i got her phone and i found some
messages that were
you know blew me away and i mean like
without giving away too much but like
what did you see well i i the first
message that i streamed it was uh it was
uh
sexting messages it was her was uh you
know they're exchanging of pictures and
of course you know i see pictures of
another guy on my wife's phone it was
just whoa and uh
the tough part about all this was you
know i
i had a feeling and then i thought to
myself you know
divorces are forever once it gets passed
through the
the machine as you call it at that point
in time
there's no turning back and i had had
friends of mine who had some miserable
divorces
and i knew that it's probably a good
thing sooner
rather than later just because of the
ramifications and repercussions long
term
you know just talk to a lawyer so i you
know i i started just
making some phone calls just kind of
seeing how the divorce process work
you know how these things go
on your phone or um just like hush-hush
kept it quiet i kept it quiet
i figured um i figured at that point in
time
let's see how this evolves and uh and
let's
let's just play stupid for right now
until i can talk to some legal experts
and get some advice so it wasn't likely
at the time though like when you
picked up your phone and you saw the you
know the exchange of messages and the
emojis and the eggplants and the
pictures and all that like
how did that sit with you oh it was
rough i i
yeah i found an excuse to get out of the
house you know immediately
you know hey um you know i got to go run
this errand she you know she was kind of
i it's not my type of personality to
just drop something and leave
um you know i'm a planner so i always
give you know ample heads up so she was
a little bit you know okay are you all
right and i'm like yeah i'm fine
and i just had to i just had to get away
from it emotionally clear my head and
you know i called my i i called a good
friend of mine at that time and it's you
know hey this is what's going on and he
had gone through a rough divorce
and his immediate recommendation was
dude go see a lawyer
go talk to a lawyer right away
you